Ron Swanson I want to thank you for
being so ruthless and cruel in a meeting
the other day you'll have to be more
specific with the public works
department about the dam ah what do you
say I take you to lunch and then we can
talk about all the projects that you
want to get accomplished that won't be
necessary I don't have any projects I
hate projects
[Music]
[Laughter]
we can talk shop what are you gonna have
I'm thinking something raw and cucumber
based
a cucumber I don't know what happened I
declined his invitation he started
laughing and the next thing I knew we
were at lunch
did he drug me
I got a second box of donuts if anybody
what the [ __ ] is this this Mr director
is your new desk okay this desk is the
epitome of the Swedish concept of
yamstow duct or equality imagine someone
needs your attention somebody say my
name Chris swivel
what is it Jerry you told me to say your
name and you did a great job Superstar
someone else say something you look like
a freak swivel
April that is not a very good attitude I
will keep my eye on you from my circular
desk where I can see everything tiny
swivel
see how it works
what about my office and its many walls
that becomes a new public waiting room
and we got rid of that giant pillar that
was in front of your door
I loved that pillar and made it really
annoying to stand in my doorway
get over it because it's gone you're
going to be more accessible than ever
excuse me
there's a sign at rampsit Park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made some tea with it and now I have an
infection
sir
sir are are you are you listening to me
sir sir I'm talking to you
sir
sir are you aware
that there is waste in your water system
Ron Swanson
just the man I wanted to see I'm going
to be going to a seminar on the art of
the Japanese tea ceremony or chagai at
the Pawnee Community College and I
thought you might like to come with me
why I know how much you value silence
a fair point but we did just have lunch
last week so I feel like we've spent
enough social time together for the
foreseeable
ever you and I will embark on a quick
session of heart rate meditation
focusing on conscious breathing and
opening the heart chakra I'm not sure
I'm interested in that
no I am sure I am not interested in that
run you and I are very different people
and we have often been in odds it is
crucial that you and I spend a day
spiritually engaged and consider what it
would really mean to work together trust
me you'll love it I'll see you tomorrow
oh where are your yoga pants
this is the best meditation center in
the area it doesn't look like much oh
actually this strip mall has
surprisingly decent cheap although the
smells from the Greek restaurant next
door are not ideal but through this
store lies a deep
foreign
excuse me ladies on your right
now take in the vibe of the room and
remain open of my mind and of spirit now
quietly
sit by me and let's join breath
I'll Stand
interesting technique
all told we were in there about six
hours and no I was not meditating
I just stood there quietly breathing
there were no thoughts in my head
whatsoever my mind was blank
I don't know what the hell these other
crackpots are doing Ron Swanson Chris
you
come up with a plan
so spectacularly horrible that it might
ruin the entire department now wait a
minute I mean that is a compliment
so it pains me to say this
my department has to go back to the way
it was give him time they'll adjust no
they won't they're miserable
Tom only performs when there's someone
to a press so marooning him on freak
Island isn't helping anyone
and you made April assistant to everyone
you know who April hates
everyone
and Jerry can only function if no one's
looking you shine a light on him and he
shrinks up faster than an Eskimo scrotum
but that's very perceptive Ron and very
graphic
I understand your point but there's no
way that I could just roll over on this
oh okay
you won't ever hear me say this again so
Savor this moment
I may have a compromise
how long do you have to do this a week
I humbly place before you my East Meets
West patented Traeger turkey burger an
Asian fusion Burger made with Willow
farms organic turkey a toasted telegio
cheese crisp papaya Chutney black
truffle aioli and micro Greens on a
gluten-free brioche bun enjoy
um this taste is delicious as Beyonce
smells
I'm guessing what is this in here is
that Bob wow somebody's got a sharp
palette I love the Umami flavor
stop being so pretentious Kyle sorry
here's mine it's a hamburger made out of
meat on a bun with nothing
add ketchup if you want I couldn't care
less
Ron
I'm so disappointed I thought that you
and I were going to have a real
challenge never mind this is better way
better
um
Kyle
sorry Andy runs is better damn it Kyle
oh my gosh so much better it's crazy
turkey can never beat cow Chris sorry
I don't understand I I've tinkered with
this recipe for years granted it's been
a long time since I've had hamburger
this is better the commissary will
continue to serve horrifying artery
clogging hamburger
all right
Ron I want to do things the Swanson way
wonderful first rule no conversation
lasts longer than 100 total words you
have used nine I have used 20. continue
fun
I'd like you to teach me to build a crib
why do you need to build your own crib
because I no longer trust anything other
than my own two hands thank you for the
woodworking lesson Ron this whole recall
thing has got me literally rethinking
everything I thought I knew about
parenting what Sleep Method will you be
using Ferber Sears Swanson method where
you close your eyes and fall asleep I
really wish Ron would engage but he
exudes so much wisdom that I can learn
parenting tips simply by being in his
presence someone like Ron is teaching
even when they're not teaching does that
make sense my anxiety has kept me up for
over 50 hours
if a joint is properly fashioned all you
need to do is guide it into place all
you need to do is guide it into place
what I get from that is when parenting
sometimes a subtle hand is more
effective than a strong one
this is already so much more helpful
than the last book in parenting I read
rad dads by Apollo Anton oh no and Sean
White
[Music]
Ron why did you throw that wood away
it's unstable it's no good I just don't
understand the throwing away the wood
metaphor what's the lesson oh I know
it's potty training that trash can is
the toilet and the wood was the feces
Chris I'm not teaching you anything
we're just building a crib no I know
you're not consciously teaching me
anything I'm just trying to siphon off
some of your calm centered wisdom
through metaphors metaphors I hate
metaphors that's why my favorite book is
Moby Dick
no frou-frou symbolism just a good
simple tale about a man who hates an
animal that's enough for today I think
an organized child no
Ron what's this the crib I built I'm
giving it to you and Anne it's perfectly
safe I tested it by hitting it with my
truck Well Ron I can't accept this is
for your baby there's more than one crib
Tree in a forest that's not a lesson by
the way just a comment on Lumber
availability
beautiful thank you nobody has all the
right answers in parenting including me
and that toxic crib you bought won't be
the last mistake you make but a man who
is this worried about making all the
right choices cares very much that's all
that matters you'll be a great father
thank you Ron for the crib and the
advice it's much better than any
metaphor
does the white whale actually symbolize
the unknowability and meaninglessness of
human existence
it's just a fish